[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture le magazine pour
vous informer des actualités culturelles
du département voici le sommaire molière
aurait eu 400 ans le 15 janvier 2022
alors pour fêter son anniversaire la vie
de saint germain les propose une
exposition à la médiathèque marc ferro
molière en couleur permet de découvrir
des dessins de personnages en costumes
d'après les comédies du célèbre
dramaturge le centre de musique baroque
de versailles célèbre lui aussi molière
un ex podcast mai consacré sur des
musiques à découvrir sur le site du cmbv
et puis enfin à saint quentin en
yvelines la fête du conte est de retour
pour une 21e édition
au programme spectacle je rencontre ou
encore ateliers dans toutes les
médiathèques on en parlera avec le dise
président délégué à la culture saint
quentin en yvelines
je vous le disais en titre la ville de
saint-quentin de saint germain en laye
fait le 400e anniversaire de la
naissance de molière jusqu'au 29 janvier
vous pourrez le découvrir l'exposition
molière en couleur à la médiathèque marc
ferro grâce à charles b tout est
dessinateur et costumier de la comédie
française des maquettes de personnages
réalisés pour des comédies de molière
sont mises à disposition des visiteurs
regardent et des costumes de magiciens
de musiciens et même de singe charles b
tout fut le principal costumier de la
comédie française de 1919 à 1939 il a
notamment dessiné des costumes pour les
personnages des pièces de molière pour
célébrer les 400 ans de la naissance du
célèbre dramaturge certains sont exposés
exceptionnellement aux visiteurs de la
médiathèque marc ferro à saint germain
en laye ce qui m'intéressait dans cette
exposition c'était son côté par la
colorée bien sûr molière en couleurs est
accessible à tous à la foire aux adultes
et aux enfants donc sur le côté grand
public qui correspond bien à notre
activité ici à notre public l'exposition
regroupe au total une vingtaine de
maquettes ses dessins sont précieux pour
la minutie et l'exactitude historique
des détails est ce qu'on remarque sur
ces images
comme sur d'autres d'ailleurs c'est la
précision des détails des costumes sur
certaines maquettes les visiteurs
peuvent également retrouver des
précisions du costumier on voit sur
cette maquette les indications de du
costumier assure voilà par exemple est
bien appliquée satin bleu tunique
lingerie teinte ruban et c'est donc ce
sont des indications pour la fabrication
des costumes l'exposition molière en
couleurs est disponible jusqu'au 29
janvier la ville de saint germain les
propose également des spectacles et des
conférences pour fêter les 400 ans du
dramaturge d'art de la nuit de la
lecture le 22 janvier les passionnés
pourront assister à des scènes extraites
des pièces de molière au sein de la
médiathèque
il n'y a pas que la ville de saint
germain en laye qui célèbre le
dramaturge les musiques de molière c'est
la deuxième édition des expos de caste
du centre de musique baroque de
versailles à découvrir sur leur site
internet
l'établissement a voulu à lui aussi
fêter le 400e anniversaire de molière on
en parle avec nicolas bûcher le
directeur du cndd
[Musique]
c'est une expo est un podcast
on va contracter c'est un ex podcasts et
donc c'est une expo qui est une expo
numérique évidemment puisque on est dans
un univers entièrement numérique entre
l'expo et le podcast
[Musique]
molière et la musique sont intimement
liés et que penser jean baptiste
poquelin pensée molière aujourd'hui sont
le relier à la musique et à l'art de
spectacles de son temps c'est perdre une
grande partie de nos merveilleux
il ya deux podcasts différentes pour
être précis il ya un peu de castes en
six épisodes qui est vraiment un podcast
qui nous guide dans les musiques de
molière delà de la jeunesse de molière
le rapport de molière avec la musique et
on va le conduire quasiment jusqu'à au
malade imaginaire justement jusqu'à sa
dernière pièce est entre-temps on va
balayer dans cette vie de molière tout
ce que molière on va voir combien avec
la musique et on va y trouver aussi un
podcast qu'on a appelée junior mais qui
est vraiment tout public en fait qui
s'adresse délester le collège et où on
va avoir cinq personnages qui vont nous
présenter leur le rapport à molière
[Musique]
et on reste au centre de musique baroque
de versailles versailles son école
maîtrisienne ouvre les inscriptions du
recrutement des pages pour la rentrée de
septembre 2022 elle s'adresse à des
élèves de 7 à 14 ans qui seront en
classe à horaires aménagées samedi 22
janvier une journée portes ouvertes est
organisée au programme présentation de
la maîtrise du cndd et ateliers des
démonstrations
ils sont 21 pour l'instant 21 sites
culturels yvelinois qui vous ouvrent
leurs portes à tarifs réduits ou
promotionnels depuis le lundi 10 janvier
vous devez tout simplement être
détenteur de la carte ou d'un abonnement
navigo en cours de validité pour
profiter de ces avantages théâtres
musées ou encore le parc france
miniature font partie des lieux
partenaires alors le muséum fournaise à
chatou le musée du jouet à poissy où le
musée de la toile de jouy propose des
tarifs réduits les château de
rambouillet de maisons laffitte font
bénéficier de tarifs spéciaux les
cinémas ne sont pas en reste ils
concèdent tous le tarif réduit bien sûr
sur présentation à chaque fois de la
carte navigo d'ailleurs une carte
interactive est disponible sur le site
ile-de-france mobilité vous pouvez
retrouver les 21 sites yvelinois et les
300 sites franciliens partenaires
du 15 au 29 janvier c'est la 21e édition
de la fête du conte le réseau des
médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines invite ses
habitants et même les tout-petits à
découvrir le conte sous toutes ses
formes éric allain jeunesse bonsoir
vous êtes le vice-président délégué à la
culture alors la fête du conte est
devenu incontournable à saint quentin en
yvelines cette année elle revient dans
les médiathèques au contact des gens
puisque l'année dernière elle était en
simplement sur le site internet nous
vous imagine que vous êtes heureux d'une
programmation en présentiel
évidemment très heureux de voir enfin la
fin du conte revenu dans son format dans
le format qu'elle n'aurait jamais dû le
laisser
sur lequel n'aurait jamais dû cesser
d'être est effectivement pour nous c'est
un grand bonheur de pouvoir faire
revenir le public dans nos métiers tech
et de retrouver donc cet espace de
convivialité alors évidemment le
contexte sanitaire nous impose des
règles extrêmement extrêmement strictes
que qui sont respectées mais bien
évidemment content que la fête soit là
et on compte fêter cette 21e fête du
conte avec avec les enfants est
un moment important pour
tel est le but cette fête du conte
le but de cette fête du conte d'abord
c'est de passer un bon moment c'est de
ces deux de retrouver les enfants de
tous âges puisque il ya des des
performances et des spectacles qui sont
prévus donc pour les tout petits en vol
18 mois à 3 ans pour certains même moins
de 18 mois tous les enfants sont invités
il ya des spectacles pour les plus
grands
voilà
l'objectif s'immoler c2c de faire
travailler aussi bien évidemment
l'imaginaire de jouer avec les numéros
de jongler avec les mots que comme je le
vois et écrit sur le programme c'est de
redonner sa place à l'imaginaire aux
comptes qui qui qui a traversé le temps
qui est incontournable qui s'est
transmis de génération en génération
c'est vrai que les enfants aujourd'hui
ont d'autres
d'autres moyens de
de s'amuser c'est vrai que le compte est
peut-être un petit peu passer au
deuxième plan d disons d de l'aspect
ludique chez les enfants mais mais on y
est on y est très attaché et on aime ce
format et on n 7 7 cette immersion dans
les mots dans la musique dans leur
imaginaire dans le voyage voilà c'est
très c'est très très important
parler de la programmation il ya des
spectacles des ateliers bien sûr des
lectures même pour les tout petits alors
est-ce que vous pouvez peut-être nous
donner deux temps forts de cette
programmation
alors on va voir un temps fort qui va
avoir lieu à la médiathèque jean clôt
avec le spectacle l'âme de génie autour
des contes des mille et une nuits donc
celle ali merghache qui nous fait un
voyage pendant une heure
on le décrit comme un enfer des arts de
la parole qui joue avec les mots avec
les sonorités il va nous amener de
samarcande à bagdad on va se perdre dans
le désert avec un jeune marchand qui va
croiser des qualifs eu des derviches des
génies enfin tout tout un tas de
personnages hauts en couleur et je pense
que le rêve et le rêve est au rendez
vous incontestablement de 2,7 deux sets
de 7 ans fort
d'être je citerai le 29 janvier donc le
à la médiathèque du phare amour avec les
aventures du loup gris
qui est aussi un incontournable et puis
peut-être aussi vous parler de la
veillée qui sera placée sous le signe
des états unis d'amérique à la
médiathèque 17 mar est en cours
le programme est riche alors j'invite
tous les toutes les personnes
intéressées à aller sur le site y tirer
médiathèque point est-ce qu y point fr
pour retrouver l'ensemble du programme
un programme très riche et très haut en
couleur et où chacun peut trouver
compte à son pied si je dirais
est le parrain de cette édition cette
année c'est gilles bizouerne auteur de
nombreux albums jeunesse alors pourquoi
l'avoir choisi et comment vous avez
travaillé ensemble
on l'a choisi d'une part parce que c'est
un c'est un orfèvre en la matière il ya
à son passif de très nombreux ouvrages
est
né à coeur de lui offrir donc 7 2 duo
fred être le parent parce que je me
trouvais que c'était quelqu'un qui était
tout à fait le tout à fait représentatif
un petit peu de cet univers du conte
pour lequel nous avons travaillé c'était
c'était très agréable de travailler avec
lui il a mis énormément d'énergie et de
coeur à faire de cette fête vraiment à
un moment tout à fait exceptionnel
on le rappelle a aussi toute l'année des
comptes en vidéo 1 sont disponibles
justement sur le site que vous venez de
dire immédiate à caen sky point fr alors
rubrique culture en ligne vous
retrouverez également tout le programme
sur le même lien comme vous l'avez dit
merci beaucoup éric allain ginès d'avoir
été notre invité ou de données nombreux
participer
retrouvons la vie retrouvons le moment
tu retrouves en leurs rêves
c'est noté merci beaucoup
ainsi vous aimez le gospel un concert
est présenté par la chorale saint
quentin gospel à l'église saint lubin et
saint jean baptiste de rambouillet
vendredi 14 janvier à 20h30 organisé par
l'entreprise l'instant event 50 % des
gains seront reversés à la paroisse on
écoutait la directrice de l'instant
event il y aura au moins 17 choristes
qui vont chanter des airs que nous
connaissons quasiment tous
avec un orchestre et et puis voilà à
l'église tout simplement en fait autant
de simplicité beaucoup de gens sont cons
prix des billets pour leurs enfants
aussi et ça c'est génial vraiment qu'ils
aient tout âge toutes origines toutes
confessions et c'est la fin de ses 7,8
culture merci de nous avoir suivis
rendez vous la semaine prochaine bonne
soirée sur tv 66
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]